just like the biggest reason i don't
cook or like i don't like cooking
is because cooking like i like cooking
cooking's great
i like the food cleaning up man it's
like the
the ratio of time it takes to clean up
versus eating good food nice
nice home-cooked food it just it just
doesn't it's it's not optimal it's it's
so
sub-optimized the entire like the entire
activity of cleaning
it's just sub-optimized in life you've
become like me i swear
no no no caring about like the splits
cleaning for me has always been
suboptimal like i don't know why this is
the one activity in life that
it's just like this needs to be balanced
there needs to be like a balanced patch
in life
that just makes cleaning less effort
it's like doing a 20-minute side quest
to get to a two-minute main question
yeah because it just does it just
doesn't make sense it takes more like
it's a side quest that takes more time
and energy than the [ __ ] main quest
you finish cleaning and you're like all
right time to get down to work cool i'm
glad i spent
30 minutes cooking this thing that took
me two minutes yeah yeah exactly
exactly right i ordered a lot of
ubereats obviously and uh
i caved and in japan they have an
ubereats pass where you can
if you uh pay nine dollars a month you
get free delivery fee right so there's
no delivery fee which is like two packs
each time yeah
and i was like [ __ ] dude am i really
ordering this much [ __ ] take out and
i was like yeah
yeah i am yeah and then i did it in my
head right i i
i did this thing where like for three
for three times when i cooked
i timed it i i didn't i didn't speed run
out or anything i was like i wasn't
doing splits or anything
i wasn't like it's benedict's eight
percent this is the onion split
oh i got a gold onions no i wasn't doing
that i just had a timer
and i timed genuinely how long it took
right yeah and then i timed cleaning up
right
because i wanted to know based on my
average earnings for a month right
i is this technically am i losing money
by by cooking myself i was like this is
how i can scientifically justify
to myself ordering takeout right right
so i split it up right
i did the ever no i know i know this
would be [ __ ] i knew you guys were
[ __ ] laughing for this this is just
hilarious
this is big brain do it yourself right
go home now i don't have to because
you've done it for us
right that i do not enjoy cooking right
so that that whole factor of enjoyment
is gone yeah i don't like that's not a
factor in my decision right but do you
do you enjoy the end result i enjoy uber
eats more
bro there is something about a home
cooked food i don't know what it is
because you can cook it exactly the way
yeah there's there's a chunk about a
home-cooked meal
if you know how to cook yeah so so my
cooking is my cooking if you don't then
it's just like honey you should try
sometimes
no no just tell lucky to be like yo i
only make
like curry and mexican that's all i made
which is
honestly it's all you need in my book
right yeah yeah so mexican food
i i can't really like make enough to
store like because
it's really [ __ ] expensive for the
ingredients as well yeah but curry i can
normally make like enough for like six
meals
all right that's just pretty nice
because then that that like the time
versus like money effort is fine but i'm
cooking
anything else because when i did this
thing i found out
that i was like wasting if you did the
time to money conversion on my earnings
to like
it was like it was like 40 percent less
efficient to cook my own meals
like a [ __ ] spreadsheet because it
was driving me insane because i was
speaking to some people who are like
those [ __ ] entrepreneur people
they're like i never cook or clean my
thing i hire a maid i i get who breeds i
don't do any of that [ __ ]
waste of time i'm on that grind 24 7. in
reality i would like an extra hour to
play video games
because in my life an extra hour to play
video games is quite a lot of time yeah
so if i can get an extra hour playing
video games and then i can then
later on spend an extra hour working
it's like okay it makes sense
to just get ubereats yeah yeah is this
just is this just conor the podcast
trying to justify his spending
no no no i i i i people problems i'm
kidding i'm joking it's
entrepreneur problems not completely i
mean i mean this is this is why
we became [ __ ] entrepreneurs right
yeah i've never [ __ ] enjoyed cleaning
in my life
i never will enjoy cleaning and you know
what's the only like
i guess like housework quote unquote
that i really enjoy yeah
doing the laundry okay laundry is nice
yeah laundry
something about laundry i really like it
it's like
it's just like i just put some music on
i'm outside well you just feel
clean yeah usually it's like a nice day
and i'm just hanging out my clothes i'm
just like hey you know what
no stress right sub-optimism that's this
is why sydney does the laundry thank you
sydney by the way this is why i get a
woman to do it
i i laugh sometimes i laugh sometimes
because like my mom's like
you're gonna need to learn how to do the
laundry someday someday and then see
competition family and then sydney comes
along and is like i love laundry
laundry's so relaxing
i'm like it is i'm like good it's the
whole thing of like your school teacher
being like you get
you're not gonna carry calculator with
you every day it's like
about that